Hi, Dr. Kevin Connors here again today for your member's minute.
We've been talking about Lyme disease and we're going to continue, so Lyme disease.
And mainly we're talking about chronic Lyme disease.
So with chronic Lyme disease, we talked about it goes into an autoimmune phase.
So remember, if you watch any of my autoimmune videos, you have two sides of your immune system.
You have your TH1 side and your TH2 side.
This is normal.
Normally, your TH1 side fires to kill a pathogen.
I got exposed to a virus, TH1 side fires, kills the virus.
I go back into balance.
I never knew I had a virus.
So in the event that it's a really bad virus, a really bad flu or bad something by TH1 fires
and understand with this TH1 side of TH2 side, they're all these different chemicals.
In this TH1 side, it's the specific cytokines and chemokines and lymphocytes and white blood cells
and macrophages that are the killers.
Think of these guys as the marine core.
They're out to kill the pathogen.
That's what their job is and they do it well.
So they're fiery to kill that pathogen.
If it's a really virulent virus or something like that and they're not able to kill it,
then this suppresses, this goes down, and the TH2 side fires.
They could the TH2 side as the CIA or the FBI.
They're out to find alkyter.
They're out to find the terrorists.
They're out to find the bad guy and they're going to tag it with an antibody.
So TH2 side primarily makes antibodies to kill that virus.
Then that suppresses and then the TH1 side fires again.
Now it can tell, oh, there you are, you little stinker, we're going to kill you.
Fires and reaction against that pathogen that's tagged with the antibody.
It kills it.
It goes back into balance.
You were sick for three days and you go back to work and you're all happy.
Well, the problem is with an autoimmune issue is that this is still not able to kill that
that line disease because it's hidden intracellular.
It fires a TH2 reaction to go and tag the Borrelia and can't find it.
It's hidden intracellular.
So it starts tagging your cells.
So in this case, with an autoimmune, you make antibodies against your own cells.
Not good.
When you start making antibodies against your own cells, that's called an auto-self immune disease.
Your body's immune system is destroying self-tissue.
Why?
Because it couldn't find the antigen.
It was hidden somewhere where the antigen wasn't even a living thing in order to be killed.
So the immune system creates antibodies against your own cells and you start destroying self-tissue.
This is what happens with all autoimmune diseases.
That's what an autoimmune disease is.
But it certainly happens with chronic Lyme.
So people that are chronic Lyme are stuck in an autoimmune reaction.
In our next videos, we'll talk about, where's the imbalance?
But it's important to know this piece first.